that was my first experience with him
and it's not like you could have run
home and go on a computer and see who
the [__] that guy was like nobody knew
we kept who's that old guy who's that
old guy and then somebody said he's a
comedian his name is rodney dangerfield
and i was off and running comedy was not
even in my [__] thoughts the only
thing was that my thoughts at that time
were eight balls that was all i thought
about there wasn't futures i didn't
think about all i thought about was
going to columbia buying the biggest
rock of coke and snorting it till i died
like sending a postcard back with me
petting like a coke rock guys
there's nights that i would just go on a
computer and go down to rodney hole you
know and he was such an inspiration to
me but when easy money came out guys it
changed everything it changed everything
on sunday nights in 1981 we used to go
to a porno place a porno theater
somewhere like in teaneck new jersey and
we just go out there to [__] beat
people up and have a good time but
even in a porno theater i never heard
nobody drinking beer my point is a lot
of comics give you permission to laugh
those are the great ones the ones that
give you permission to laugh when rodney
would touch his tie when he would touch
his nose that's a gesture to get you to
laugh that's a [__] psyche type thing
that's a deep deep [__] comic
who really thought about all the
possibilities before he got on stage
very joe roganisk one thing about joe
rogan that [__] does his work
for stand up blow up the outside world
by soundgarden that's chris cornell's
[__] love for the beatles that's it
listen to it it's right there when you
something
seems to kill me yeah that's [__] the
beatles bill bellamy taught me how to
smile on stage you ever see bill bellamy
not smiling on stage he's always smiling
did i always smile on stage not really
but at least that was in the back of my
mind it was always in my ammunition box
that is one of the best sets you'll ever
[__] see in your life dlhu will come
up as an emcee and get a standing
[__] ovation are you [__] kidding
me
that's what i looked at that's how the
[__] do you get a standing ovation when
you're the first comic up and there's a
[__] headliner you want to explain
that one to me harry comes up to me i
gotta give you something this week i'll
call you give me your number sure enough
i got a call from my agent and she goes
i just got a call here i have an
audition for you for the new rodney
dangerfield movie
i'm like what
it was harry
who got me the audition
for rodney's movie
i learned these [__] sides backwards
and forwards i know them in spanish
japanese english you know there's a
rodney movie
guys i go in the waiting room i signed
my name i have my head shot and they go
joey diaz i get up i go in how you doing
and i walk in the room it's [__]
hairy basil
and [__] rodney dangerfield
guys this is too [__] surreal for
uncle joey i told you guys
listen in life
if you put the [__] work in from your
[__] heart don't worry about what
mike's doing don't worry about what
joey's doing don't worry about what
lee's doing the steve simone just worry
about what you're doing the universe
will [__] give you light
this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday march the 21st the joint is
brought to you by
manscape you smell that
i think it's your [__] balls it's
monday morning [__] uncle joey
and manscape are sending you to the
showers save big by going to
manscape.com
and i'm going to save you 20 off and
free shipping with code diaz d i a z
there's nothing like taking a shower
right you eat a little [__] honey nut
cereals
you go in the shower you start your day
trimming your [__] hairs with the
waterproof lawnmower 4.0 if you got no
power it's got a light to let you know
where your dick is then you lather on
the cologne infused ultra premium body
wash with aloe vera and sea salt to keep
your skin feeling [__] clean and
moisturize all day then you apply the
two in one shampoo and conditioner and
it cleanses my [__] hand nourishes
the three hairs i have plus i shampoo
and condition all the other little hair
patches i have around my nut sack the
three hairs in my [__] now to keep
that bo at bay you got to get the
aluminum free deodorant from manscape it
dries clear tremendous
now if you got tattoos or dry skin or
[__] rashes like me hit your skin
with the hydrating body moisturizing
spray and before you step out
you got some manscape lip balm but
that's not for you that's for the girl
because when your balls are nice and
clean
that's what she's gonna need magnifique
you ever get your dick sucked with lips
lip [__] bomb on their lips and an
ice cube in their mouth it's a party
anyway get twenty percent off and free
shipping with code diaz d-i-a-z
manscape.com again that's 20 off plus
free shipping at manscape.com use
code diaz and if you want to copy my
little shower routine i'll send you a
[__] video [__] that's
manscape.com
the joint is also brought to you by
on it listen
when it comes to supplements
honor is number one i live on that
[__]
alpha brain especially a new
[__] alpha brain improved jesus
christ i'm looking through [__] walls
do yourself a favor
you're not thinking right things are a
little rough start with the honor alpha
brain
that's the flagship [__] company
product
plus we got new mood we got a bunch of
stuff listen i can't save you money on
the club bells and stuff but as far as
supplements use code joey or church and
get 10 off delivered to your house
now you need to hydrate yourself listen
they've been my sponsors for months
and i didn't know what this product had
to offer it's liquid iv
when you're working out you want the
best the best equipment the best routine
now liquid iv is here to give you the
best hydration listen when i got the
covert i started drinking it
unbelievable whether it's sea acai the
cherry the grape one stick of liquid iv
in 16 ounces of water hydrates you
faster than water alone it's made with
pre premium products okay
it's vegan non-gmo and gluten-free and
they're supporting front-line workers to
stay healthy
over 19 million servings have donated so
far for liquid iv but that's not why i'm
reaching out to you the product is great
and i want to save you money if you go
to costco they sell them in bulk that's
fine i'm here to save you 25
look at how expensive it is i'm going to
save you 25
when you go to liquidity.com and use
code joey at checkout 25
off anything you order when you use
promo code joey at
liquidive.com i [__] love it start
off with the cherry the acai the
tropical the grape is tremendous
experience better hydration today at
liquidity.com
promo code joey now without further ado
it's the rodney dangerfield episode
[__] i love you
welcome to uncle joy's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here on a tip top my good
monday [__] morning
great weekend great [__] it's
starting to get warm out
all you [__] penguins get back in
your caves [__] i don't want to
see your spring is in the [__] air
duck ducks great weekend you know i had
a good week last week i worked
i did a documentary on rodney
dangerfield uh rick rubin's putting
something together
i gotta tell you it was [__]
mind-blowing
it really was i'm a big rodney fan when
i got the call
five months ago they were like joey you
know we want to know what you know about
rodney i'm like [__]
what don't i know about rodney i studied
that [__] like a savage
you know like i read as much as i could
about rodney when i was growing up like
not growing up as uh as i was coming up
in comedy
rodney was
i loved richard pryor growing up
right no there was no argument there
but when i saw [__] rodney walk out
on that little short walk on uh
caddyshack and he comes out shaking and
he tells
the line in that was when he told
the guy ted knight's wife
that [__]
his wife could have been something
before electricity like his wife must
have been something
before electricity but he said it so
very like like he just looked and he
goes huh look at your wife she must have
been something before electricity and
all this [__] i [__] lost everything
i had when he said that that whole style
over [__] ran me when i first saw
rodney i thought he was one of the guys
that hung out at my mother's ball like
i'm like this is one of these [__]
savages i gotta
goddamn my mom's dead i gotta figure out
what this guy's name like i knew him
like everybody [__] knew rodney and
it was all us young kids it was a bunch
of [__]
16 year olds and [__] that were [__]
rodney crazy everybody's jumping up and
down over lover boy and all these
[__] young guys and we're like
[__] rodney as king people like he's
an old man but that old man
has [__] flared to him man i uh
that was my first experience with him
and it's not like you could have run
home
and go on a computer and see who the
[__] that guy was like nobody knew we
kept who's that old guy who's that old
guy and then somebody said he's a
comedian
his name is rodney dangerfield and i was
off and running i was off and [__]
running when i saw him you know listen
comedy was not even in my [__]
thoughts the only thing was that my
thoughts at that time were eight balls
that was all i thought about there
wasn't futures i didn't think about all
i thought about was going to colombia
buying the biggest rock of coke and
snorting until i died like sending a
postcard back with me petting like a
coke rock guys
i wish i was [__] lying to you those
are my expectations at the age of
[__] 20.
yeah my pet [__] rug like that's all
i wanted i wanted to go to columbia and
take a picture with a big coke rock and
send it to the states that was
this [__] that was my loser
goal in life so when you guys analyze
your goals and go [__]
i gotta switch it up a little bit think
of you uncle joey and his biggest goal
at 21 and at this time i didn't write
goals i didn't have goals i didn't know
what a [__] goal was i just thought
you woke up in the morning you stabbed
somebody you took that money and you
lived their life there was no goals
there was nothing like that
so i see this [__] old man and i'm
like what the [__]
so you know i graduated high school well
i quit high school
the whole [__] uh deal like go to
colorado
and uh
i don't know what i went to see
i went to this movie theater in aspen
they only opened up like on fridays and
saturdays and
i went up there to see something
i can't [__] remember and i saw the
trailer
for easy money
and i lost my [__] mind
i'm like that old guy is coming out with
another move by now i know who he was i
had seen him on the tonight show there
was one set he's done on the tonight
show because
for people who don't know the rodney
story i'm gonna give it to you in a
[__] puerto rican note okay
it's basically the guy was doing
stand-up he did a couple things and then
he dropped out of the scene
he took a couple years off to uh
work he was an aluminum siding
salesman this is the beauty about rodney
dangerfield
but he kept
writing all those years that he was
working he kept writing jokes writing
jokes writing jokes
so by the time this [__] got
back on stage i don't know i don't know
how many notebooks he had here like four
[__] notebooks filled with those
one-liners
so when he got that
little spotlight from caddyshack
he started doing the tonight show
you know like religiously like every
three months the way i was doing rogan
you know
and i got to tell you something every
time he would go on it he would be
funnier and [__] funnier that was his
secret that he had four [__]
notebooks filled with jokes
ready to unleash on the [__] world
and every time he had a performance the
sets were better so you're like this guy
didn't tell this guy did not repeat a
[__] joke he had hours of those i'm
ugly
you know when i was so when i was a kid
that was so ugly when we played
trick-or-treat nobody came looking for
me all that [__] you know all that all
that [__] he had hours of that [__] and
his book you know in his notebooks so
when he came back he was strung on a
[__] whip
you know when he did caddyshack he
wanted to quit
listen everything i do is to learn like
when i got analyzed that for some people
like oh joey that's great you know the
movie sucked but
i did got that movie for one reason i
wanted to talk to harold ramus i just
wanted to talk to harold ramos that's it
i didn't care about de niro
i didn't care about anthony lompoglia i
don't give a [__] i wanted to talk to
harold ramus
and i read years later before like in
between the rhema stuff
i've always caught up on rodney you know
whenever they do like a show on rodney
on tv i watch it
there's nights that i would just go on a
computer and go down a rodney hole you
know
and he was such an inspiration to me
but when easy money came out guys
it changed everything
i used to go to move i'm a movie buff i
went to the movies
every week twice a week minimum for
[__] years old movies new movies two
dollar movies i didn't give a [__] that
was my escape as a child to go into a
[__] movie and all my years guys
you've heard all my stories about the
longest yard the cinema union city
[__]
office and the gentleman in harlem you
know enter the dragon the exorcist all
those [__] movies i went to i swear
to god i swear to god i never heard a
person
crack open a [__] beer
in all those years and all those movie
theaters on sunday nights
in 1981 we used to go to a porno place a
porno theater somewhere like in teaneck
new jersey and we would just go out
there to [__] beat people up and have
a good time
but
even in a porno theater i never heard
nobody drinking beer my point is
i'm i'll never forget going to easy
money and like my friend knowing you
know we're gonna stop and get an eight
pack and i'm like i'm gonna
[__]
you know smuggling eight pack in the
movie theater it's [__] july or
something like it was hot
he goes we're gonna put in our shorts
and our underwear and we went into this
[__] movie theater and i'm like
really quiet trying to be like i was a
savage back then but i don't want to get
thrown out of a rodney dangerfield movie
so i'm just hitting the beers real light
and i'm drinking from them and i'm not a
drinker
but
within minutes
everybody who was drinking put their
beer bottles down and let them roll down
the movie theater
so somebody started with that [__] right
about like 10 minutes into the movie
somebody let a bottle roll down the
thing and you know what it'd be about
there's nobody's gonna sneak at you
into the [__] movie theater you know
what i'm saying like a glass view
these [__] and after that all
you heard was like a war you even hear
like when they have like a world war war
on like tv you hear like all these bombs
that's what you heard after that like
once one guy let the beer bottle go
everybody you heard it every [__]
five minutes
the beer bottle spinning and hit
the attendants were [__] pissed
everybody was pissed movies sold out let
me tell you something
there's a couple [__] movies i
remember going to guys like the
excitement of being in the movie theater
like [__] i can't even describe to
you
all those early bruce lee movies when we
used to go to the city
to chinatown to all that [__] all those
kung fu theaters and [__]
those movies were live they were like
interactive
movies and we didn't even know it in
1970 interactive how joey there was
always a [__] good fistfight
there was always a tremendous fistfight
in the [__] show either two opposing
schools a judo school from the bronx and
like a [__] top keto school from
harlem and they'd be in the same movie
theater and they'd [__] go off i
think
one of the best movies i ever saw in the
movie theater i got to be honest it was
the longest yard the original
guys everybody was on their feet 19
[__] 783 i was 10 or 11.
the long the uh
rocky
the first time i saw rocky
the movie theater were on their feet
guys in the 70s we got up and if the
movie was too good we got up on the
chair
like for the longest yard and rocky as a
child i remember still being on the
chair yelling rocky rocky like a [__]
[__] you know you're a kid man what
do you expect you know but all that [__]
that was interactive movie go to a movie
now and take your cell phone out there's
always that one [__] [__] excuse
me can you put your phone away mind your
[__] business 15 years ago you could
be stabbing a [__] movie
theater and nobody was saying nothing
nobody would turn and go shh you know
they didn't give a [__] stab them i'm
over here getting a hand job in the
popcorn box you would do that you put
your dick in the popcorn box they gonna
get it and give you a little cappuccino
you throw the popcorn out you put your
dick in the hole you guys never did that
what type of [__] catholics are you
[__]
but the the movies were always like
[__] interactive
then the latest movies that i went to
see were like rambo
and 85 that [__] black movie
theater in harlem on 178th street
went off the wall but let's not get
ahead of ourselves
easy money
that movie theater when i went to see
the [__] movie the first day was
filled with adolescence 70. you could
smell the sperm and the pimple
medication it was all of us
had [__] pimple medication on that
clearassil [__] that's all you could
smell in the theater you don't want to
mix that with the smell of sperm sperm
and clarissa
do not [__] go i mean the whole
[__] movie theater and i walked out
of that my head was [__] gone guys i
was like
what the [__] did i just see rodney
was on a roll and somewhere another you
know rodney stuck in my psyche and then
i heard stories about him over the years
that he got high
when i found out rodney dangerfield was
a pothead are you kidding me i started
smoking with three [__] hands and a
lot of people it's like it's not rodney
didn't walk around with a 420 shirt
but he smoked
all [__] day
you guys have no idea and we'll get into
it in a minute so
you know i i'm still not into comedy
back to school comes out that's 87 86.
rodney steals the show he's got tennyson
in there he's got a bunch of [__]
comics in
and i'm still not into comedy like i'm
like ah i
guys i wasn't even thinking about comedy
i'm not gonna go comedy oh yeah no
that wasn't even i was still stealing
and eight balls was still the name you
know what i'm saying you had to knock
down the eight ball is the king of my
hobbies
so
[__] embarrassing when you're a loser
but uh
so i don't know what the [__] happened i
ended up getting locked up blah blah
blah and then dice came out
dice came out and dice just
[__] stole me away my comedy loyalty
you know
but i was always a prior guy like i was
always a [__] pride guy
rodney
you know stepped up and and stole my
heart somewhere along the line like
rodney was like everybody i had grown up
with like they all had their little
[__] stuff to him
that easy money when joe pesci
is smoking pot and he takes the joint
out of the roach motel he has a roach
motel in his bathroom and he [__]
hits it
and then rodney's smoking dope with his
daughter's [__] eyelash things
guys come on come on guys you know you
just see these are rough necks and i was
[__] i was relating to him i was i
was sitting there in that movie today
going that's me going to the track and
[__] getting in fights and strip
clubs you know uh he's the one guys
talking to the girl and easy money and
joe pesci comes over and he goes is
there a problem and the guy goes yeah
you guys getting a little rough with the
girls here he goes excuse me
don't lay take your hands off him do you
know who i am
no who are you because i'm the guy that
installed the bathrooms in this joint
and the strip club owner goes that's why
the place thinks so bad and you get into
a [__] fight all that [__] that's
[__] adolescent kid [__] that's 18
year old [__] but listen when it's on
now easy money i still [__] watch it
and guys i giggle like it was the first
time
listen i never stole nothing
from rodney but there's so many things i
learned from him they open your mind
there's a scene in easy money
when he's trying to lose weight
and he's in the room like eating
strawberries and this kid is practicing
the violin
and she's doing like you know scales
and rodney can't take it the more he's
trying to build the model and he's
shaking his [__] and finally just puts
the model down he grabs a kitchen knife
this [__] big and he starts to stab
himself but he catches his own hand and
that's the scene of him going
rose rose
stop it stop it because he can't [__]
listen to the violin music and he's
going to stab himself nobody's ever done
that type of funny [__]
nobody
so
i mean rodney had my heart there so now
dice comes along
87 88 you know i get locked up i get
[__]
released two years later and dice is the
man on the [__] street and i ran with
him i never dropped rodney rodney was
always my core comedian he was the guy
that lived inside my head right like i
always heard rodney in my head
i hung out with a kid roger holloway god
bless his soul just
he was another [__] rodney guy and he
made me laugh he had all those rodney
one lighters you know the [__] hand
gestures the whole thing
but then comedy came calling
and i went to uh a video store you know
that was in boulder it was the biggest
video store on the west coast it was
three floors at the time
and i asked them about a stand-up
section you know
one of the guys on my patreon john
mickelson good great guy here they said
he went to a comedy show
and he said that
he was talking to some of the comics and
that the comics didn't know
who the [__] anybody was like they
didn't really know like
who their peers were it's like me going
with your musician and going do you
listen to alice and james and they're
like nah not really i don't even know
they are you're like
how can you be a musician you know
you're not a student of the game
before you get into any of these things
that you're
whether it's music whether it's art
whether it's whatever the [__] it is
you have to be a student of the game
listen i don't want you to [__] tell
me like
i'ma tell you who's a student of the
game
with all his [__] pot smoking
all the other [__] in his life the
reason why i give him the respect that
he deserves
is mike tyson
you could talk to mike tyson about
anything
first time i met mike tyson i had like a
t-shirt on
with this cuban box of kid chocolate
that nobody knows about
a lot of people praise kid chocolate
like a lot of older boxers love kid
chocolate
but nobody talks about kid chocolate
[__] mike tyson
did it gave me a 35 minute [__]
lecture
on kid chocolate on all his fights where
he trained how he came to new york city
and he [__] got big eating steaks and
i'm like mike i'm [__] cuban i don't
even know all this [__]
and that's not where it ends mike tyson
could take you back to the first bed
knuckle fight
1655 in england you know
mike tyson will tell you he could be
there like you know mike what time is it
uh uh i don't [__] not mike
these two guys fought in [__] 1865.
michael just drill you out
that's what it takes to be a champion
sometimes you really gotta whether you
like them or not listen i love bob
newhart i [__] love bob noah
love bob newhart as a comic love bob
newhart
the whitest
not non-cursing guy
non-confrontational comic you've ever
listened to in your life i [__] love
them
nobody talks about them
bob nour joy
i don't see you as a fan of bob newhart
because you're a [__] jerk off
because if you know anything about me i
have
borrowed or gotten inspired
by a legion of [__] comedians just
because i don't have my nose of jerry
seinfeld's ass
doesn't mean i don't respect jerry signs
up i'll sit here and say something bad
about jerry seinful personality or he's
a dick you don't even say hello to
nobody
all that
all that i sweep
because
even jerry seinfeld contributed to my
stand up i love jerry's writing jerry
has a [__] joke on one of those
rodney specials
that he says how does the hair in the
shower move up doesn't have legs
even though this time when you're in the
shower there's always hair and it just
moves up the wall it doesn't have like
all those things you know like when
jerry had a joke about [__] if you
don't want to talk to people don't jump
in the shower
that you can't talk to people when
you're in the shower excuse me i'm on
the phone i want to talk to jerry i
can't get to him he's in the shower you
know all that all that
so when for me to learn about jerry
seinfeld
i'm not a big huge george carlin guy
but there's some [__] george carlin did
that [__] rocked my world
you know tomato tomato all that [__]
rock my world but i don't but joey you
don't have a a george carlin post it
doesn't mean nothing
i took a piece of him somewhere in my
routine
instead of jokes joey no i took a piece
of him maybe a look
maybe a gesture
you know the thing i liked about rodney
is he gave you permission to laugh
for you guys yeah for you guys who don't
know what i'm talking about a lot of
comics give you permission to laugh
those are the great ones the ones that
give you permission to laugh
joey what are you talking about
permission life when rodney would touch
his tie
when he would touch his nose
that's a gesture to get you to laugh
that's a [__] psyche type thing
that's a deep deep [__] comic
who really thought about all the
possibilities before he got on stage
very joe roganisk one thing about joe
rogan that [__] does his work
for stand up
he investigates he [__] researches
me i'm just a bump i'm just a [__]
bum from that [__] but i have
borrowed a piece of all those great
comics you have to
you know wait when you're in a musician
you don't borrow little pieces full on
sound garden super unknown the album of
the week on patreon last week
i think there's two songs in there that
are very beetle-ish
once you get into
uh the song with right the album
rhinosaur on it on the flip side
whatever
uh
the outside world blow up the outside
world by soundgarden
that's chris cornell's [__] love for
the beatles that's it listen to it it's
right there when you something
seems to kill me yeah that's [__] the
beatles
you know so did he steal from the
beatles no
you could just tell he was a student of
the [__] game from the beatles
so to create joe diaz i had to study all
a bunch of comics and the ones i loved
and you're not even gonna believe this
joe tori i rented uh the best of bet
in 2000 1991 i rested at 94.
i would watch the best of bet on this
dvd right yeah
vhs
and the two guys on there that i studied
with joe tory and bill bellamy
but joey you've never mentioned real
bell so what i'm just telling you that
bill bellamy taught me how to smile on
stage
you ever see bill bellamy not smiling on
stage he's always smiling
did i always smile on stage not really
but at least that was in the back of my
mind it was always in my ammunition box
when things get a little funky smile at
the end of that joke
and they'll put a little calming effect
on it these are all things that a lot of
the
a lot of people don't see unless you're
into comedy but back to rodney all those
comics when i went to that video store
the first video i got was the best of
bet
joe tory's got a joke in there that his
brother
this is what i used to do guys when i
even though i was on coke i never
watched this [__] on coke because i
couldn't absorb
what they were selling me i couldn't
absorb what the television or the video
was telling me
but yo tory and when i first met joe at
the
if you guys got a minute watch amazon
they have a show about uh
fat tuesday it was the the best black
show [__] in l.a for years
and they gave me an opportunity
performing there and it was really uh
it was really an honor because i had
watched joe torrey i studied joe torre
you know and
for me to walk to the comedy store and
see joe torre in those days i almost
died a lot of you guys don't know who
joe torre is he's he's the sidekick in
uh
the movie with janet jackson and tupac
he's the sidekick in that he's [__]
phenomenal on that as a
as uh i studied a lot of black comics in
the beginning i love black comedy
so uh
him the guy who did bebe's kids robin
harris was one of my [__]
you know when he played uh big dick
willy uh sweet dick willie and do the
right thing
come on dog who calls himself sweet dick
willie you know what i'm saying
[Music]
so it's funny how
joe torrey used to have a joke that he
had to save the whale brother
[__]
you know [__] out there saving
the whales this [__] don't have
a [__] clue what's going on in the
world i just bought a gun and he didn't
like that either when i bought that gun
he didn't you shouldn't buy a gun what
are you gonna do with a gun he goes i
need a gun i live in l.a i need a
[__] [__] gun and he goes
now i'm dying to shoot a [__] he
goes i'll go to the atm at three in the
morning dressed up in a tuxedo and [__]
and come on where you at you're in the
bushes you get out of the boat all that
[__] i study guys as dumb as you think
that joke is when i met joe torre at the
store i repeated that joke when he's
like damn you're [__] serious i'm
like man i studied that [__] bill
bellamy
martin [__] lawrence as a host
dl hewgley as a host in bet and
meanwhile
d.l got a standing ovation as a host
on b-e-t you ready for this our standing
ovation find it on [__] youtube
that is one of the best sets you'll ever
[__] see in your life
dlhu we come up as an mc
and get a standing [__] ovation are
you [__] kidding me
that's what i looked at that's how the
[__] do you get a standing ovation
when you're the first comic up and
there's a [__] headliner you want to
explain that one to me so those are the
guys i [__] say it's true
i'm i loved all that [__] guys but for
me to get to where i was going i had to
get deep deep deep deep into [__]
deep in this [__] because that's the
only way i felt comfortable is if i knew
the a b's and c's like if mike was going
to start a band you put on the beatles
like zeppelin a little [__] you mimic
whatever the [__] and you study and you
study different things you learn about
the recording styles you know the guy
from soundgarden
took his base cord and put on his guitar
there's always a [__] story you know
i owe me switch them around i don't
[__] know i'm not a [__]
aficionado but if this is what you want
to get into these are things you got to
look
so i was looking at all those bt things
and thing and i was running out of them
and one day i go in the guy's like have
you ever seen rodney's stand-up specials
with a bunch of open micros and [__] and
i was like no
he goes i got it let me get it's like
called you get no respect or something
there's two of them
guys it's like 12 comics and two tapes
listen i could send you gene parades
writing book to give you exercises
on writing
i could recommend a bunch of things to
you guys let me tell you a little
quick reference about what happened
last year september 22nd i started going
to jiu jitsu
first couple weeks i struggled i
couldn't move around then i realized i
needed a warm up but i'm stiff in the
beginning
so i started [__] uh
warming up and stuff and then i joined
the class and i go to a big class now
there's 20 people in the class and you
got gotta run and you gotta [__] do
hip escapes and you gotta do all this
[__]
you know little by little
i have a job i've been there since
september i started the classes in
december the end of november so by now i
got a lid on the classes right and i was
just thinking about this last week
i got a uh i got promoted to uh i could
now i could go to two more classes at
the school they offer like six different
classes
some of them a drill class someone you
know
i go to this class called blue
it's a blue black class and what this
class is it's basically
you do a warm-up
you
uh do a warm-up you learn something then
you do
king of the hill like seven or eight
guys you have to break the guard or pass
the guard
two minute drills and it builds you up
and then at the end then you go back to
drilling
what you learn at the end you roll with
people to close out the class
it's so weird how people always go well
i want to join a gym and get it i want
to get in shape before i join the gym
you know with jiu jitsu i'm a little
older so i went online i
and i studied all this [__] about you
know
oh man jiu jitsu and how to train
differently because you're a little
older
but when i went to class on thursday
last week
that all went out the window what i'm
trying to say to you guys is that
you know i go to the gym two three days
a week i ride the bike i hit the bag i
do little [__] things just to stay
but nothing could prepared me for what i
went through on [__] thursday i was
flying through the [__] air i was
getting thrown around i enjoyed it i'm
not complaining about it but what i'm
trying to say is
nothing could prepare me for that like
as much as i wanted to swing kettlebells
and get in shape
for rowan nothing prepares you for that
you have to go in there and roll and
it's the same thing with stand-up you
could look in the mirror you could go on
instagram
you could [__] go on facebook and you
could shoot videos with your [__]
friends
it's not stand-up
it's not staying you could be doing all
those things aside from it
trying to get you to that spot it's not
[__] stand up okay
how do you get in stand up shape by
getting in stand up shape by doing stand
up
we're talking about me working on a
wednesday you know what i had to drive
an hour in new york driving our back i
sat there for an hour and a half and i
talked for like two hours when i got
home wednesday i was tired i'm not in
work in shape
you know what i'm saying like i'm not
working shape how do you get work in
shape well you should run two miles a
day now
by working and it's the same thing with
stand-up
you can do whatever you know i wrote i i
did a podcast that's not going to better
your stand up
those are things you could do to help
you stand up i agree with you but
they're not going to improve your stand
up and it's the same thing with stand-up
you have to watch it
you know but at the same time you got to
go out and perform what you're learning
you can just watch so much stand up if
you're a stand-up i want you to study
the people
and make notes about
you know what they're
you know with [__] uh rodney he had a
great stage presence i love there's one
liners and even if you don't like that
style i hey listen you don't like that
style that's not what i'm talking about
i want you to know that style exists
that's all
you know when uh the other day got into
jimmy florentine's car and he put on
japanese heavy metal
did you hear it
[__] pretty good
you know sakisaki i don't know godzilla
or some band i don't know
did i buy their albums not really they
were great
i learned that they exist
so as a musician i'm not gonna buy their
album but i'm gonna listen to it what
are they doing over in japan holy [__]
listen to that guitar sound what did he
do oh he was eating sushi put sushi on
the string or something like that you
know whatever
that's all things to help your career
so these are all the things that you're
gonna have to do [__] anyway you know
a lot of older comics are going on the
road this summer
and i see like two or three of them are
taking younger guys you know
and a couple of guys are going on the
road and taking youtube guys and there's
this one youtube guy i was looking at
the other day
my friend asked me did you know that
this guy was going on the road with this
young guy and i don't know i don't even
know who that guy is
and i actually put on one of his uh
tapes just to see what a guy was i want
maybe he's really good i don't know
guy was [__] terrible he's a youtube
sensation comic i got nothing against
these guys nothing
but he's trying to reinvent the wheel
with stand up like he's like well
you don't need to go to clubs you know
how many comics are really thinking
about instagram and all this listen i
appreciate what you're saying and what
you're doing but it's not stand up and
at the end you could put on the fancy
clothes you could put on earrings your
little skull cap you could smoke a
cigarette to be mysterious if you don't
come through on that stage that little
act ain't gonna sell for you and i'm
wrong there because there's a lot of
little comedians now that have little
acts that you [__] dummies buy
into
and then you go see him the comic is
[__] horrible but you're impressed
because he's got tattoos or he smokes on
stage he's so dark go [__] yourself all
right go [__] yourself
the comic offers you from the [__]
heart you never see me go up on stage
with an earring
or a [__] shirt or a hat to be cool
no because at the end of the day it's
what comes out of your [__] stomach
and through your heart to process it
that matters so that [__] little
outfit you're putting on
that little [__] you know get up you
got on that you whatever it's going to
help you with that crew that gets
impressed by that look at him he's oh
yeah that's great but how many times i'm
gonna pay the small 25 for you remember
that just remember that before you put
an outfit on i think it's cool to take a
drink up on stage you know you know look
at me i'm drinking yeah yeah you fit a
[__] category but you didn't give me
what i came to see if i wanted to see a
bunch of [__] poses i could have gone
to a [__] you know i didn't want to
see a bunch of poses i want the [__]
meat from the [__] potato here so
that's how i looked at things you know i
wasn't the best stand
but let me tell you something when i
went up there you got your [__]
money's worth i put my heart on that
[__] stage i almost risked having a
heart attack you know many times i left
off the [__] stage going i'm
surprised i didn't [__] die tonight
you know how many but i did that to give
you the value of the [__] dollar
anyway back to [__] rodney
dangerfield we went off the [__]
crew there for a second
jimmy's a big rodney fan and that's our
connection like he just
rodney's just as [__] savage you know
and dice was there
so the guy recommended at the store for
me to watch
the rodney thing and i was like rodney
really why i brought him home i didn't
know what to expect
and it was an education guys
the educator listen if if if you're down
to bad bones
and you're looking to get into comedy
here's the [__] solution you're ready
grab a pen
get both the rodney tapes on amazon i
don't care if you're buying me used
they're on there they're on there
because i look all the time you got
nothing or something like that you got
nothing with an n-u-t-h-i-n
well you got barry sobel you got lenny
clark you got [__]
roseanne schimmel you got 12.
jim carrey you've got 12 of the best
comics of a generation going up and you
got rodney hosting
are you [__] kidding me
are you [__] kidding me that's the
bible to stand up just watching bill
hicks
follow andrew dice clay
like nothing happened and andu took that
room apart
piece by piece you could see him from
stage
throwing grenades into different
sections and people's heads blowing up
and bill hicks followed him
it's a [__] education if you're a
comic and you're not studying the bill
except following andrew dice clay get a
different [__] career it's not going
to work out for you
that's
when you want to get out of a hole you
watch bill hicks what he does in that
set
and that's why you could hey listen i'm
a junkie i'm a lot of things but i was a
student of that [__] game and me
being a student of the game
was what got me in with joe joe didn't
listen like i said a thousand times
joe's got no reason to like me you ever
think about that
we have nothing in common he's a [__]
savage i'm a [__] criminal but
our mutual respect
came from the respect i had for him and
his stand-up and the respect he had for
me and my stand-up knowledge number one
my stand-up because i had a different
approach to
stand up i had an honest view when you
bomb you bomb don't blame it on the
microphone don't blame it on the sound
you bumped take it like a man and move
the [__] on nothing's gonna save you you
know who's gonna save you [__] you
what's the answer
notice what you did wrong stop saying it
was the [__] audience and your wife
stopped saying all that [__] it was you
write down what you did wrong and go
find this set and [__] correct
corrected it's that goddamn easy that's
how easy this [__] career is that's
how easy life is it goes back to you
you're eating too much chocolate throw
the [__] chocolate out of the house
why are you buying chocolate bring it to
your house if you read the [__] pound
of it the neighbor gave me a pound of
[__] razor nets i went to see batman
i told the other day i got a [__]
raisin that's what terrible they didn't
have razor nets they had like [__] uh
raisin company put chocolate on ray it
was terrible she goes i'm gonna bring
you the best raisin that's in the world
i thought she's gonna bring me a box or
a bag she brought me a costco [__]
container i had to hide it
[Music]
anyway
so when i rented that rodney thing
i studied that
at night
in the daytime i would wake up and write
or hustle a job or a bag of coke
and at night my goal was to do two
[__] sets with what i had learned
from that particular comic from the
night before
that was it
i studied that [__] to no end
but in the meantime
i really fell in love with rodney
something about rodney
when i got to l.a
um
you ever read a book you were like if
you read a book on italy
you're going to read about this palermo
whatever this part of italy
you're not really going to learn until
you get there so you put the pieces
together it's like anything else it's
like uh
it's like anything else and it's the
same with stand up you could watch these
two things you could
i could talk to you about standing up
for hours and charge you all the money
in the world until you're going to be
the best stand-up in the world i'm not
doing anything for you if i'm your
stand-up coach basically i pick you up
at seven o'clock
and we go to three or four different
spots we tape your sets
we write no it's not the end of the
night we go to a diner and wrap it up
what'd you do wrong what'd you do right
put this joke here put this joke there
you know there's a [__] science for
this guys it's not just
going up there trust me i had a hard
time
uh understanding the science
but
after a while i i i just had a [__]
uh
surrender to it or i knew i wouldn't get
anywhere in my career that's it that
that's it guys it's that [__] easy if
you want to do that
i
moved to l.a and i just uh
when i got to la i started watching a
lot more stand-up
i would go to the store watch
moony
and those guys channeling you know
and then i would go home at night and
write what i learned at the store and i
would
just comp you know just compare notes i
was always [__] learning
but when i got that way i started seeing
those guys that weren't the rodney
specials barry sobel
schimmel
uh
you know
i saw robert townsend at the store a few
times he was very good on that
so i started seeing these guys come to
life and and
in a way for me it was like
you know what i could come to life i've
never
done a set with rodney or anything and i
asked around
to see if rodney ever came out but
rodney was never in l.a when i was there
and i never ever ever
got to see him at the comedy store or
got to see him perform or anything like
that
my claim to fame of rodney
goes right here [__] i loved
rodney
i had never met him i had never seen him
uh or everything i knew about rodney was
on tape and then later on
what i had read on the internet right
so
i'm at the store
i'm a [__] schlub
it's uh
2003.
you know i had no success at stand-up at
the time
i had success booking some stuff
i was ripping i was rocking and rolling
at the [__] store and having a great
time and
you know they have those late spots at
the store
and i'll tell you when you're a young
comic or you i just got to stop saying
young
when you're any [__] comic you hate
those
spots you know they
in a way they reflect where your career
is you know what i'm saying so if you
get a spot between nine and
10 30 you're [__] the real deal
if you get a spot after you know 11 45
until two in the morning you're in
development and you come to terms with
that you learn that that you're going to
go up
that hot crowd that was there at eight
o'clock they ain't there no more
they left
so you're working with a bunch of people
working with two guys that went on dates
and the girls got sick
you're working with two other guys that
went on dates and the girls
bought drugs and sucked the dealer's
dick and they left them stranded on
sunset you left with those type of
schlubs in the audience you know when
you go up at midnight at the store
it's just a bunch of [__] you know
stragglers if that's what you want to
call so
you know i would go down there i would
do my
[__] spot at in the original room
and at that time i was dying a slow
death maybe midnight 12 15
and then mitzi would let me close out
the [__] main room but joey you're
closing out you're a headliner
save it
i'm closing it out for [__] eight
people who are drunk and don't know what
the [__] i'm talking about
so i would go back there i would do my
original store spot hold off on doing
coke
because i had to do the main room paid
you like 200
at a time when i couldn't make rent so
200 for me was like playing at the
[__] garden you know what i'm saying
so i would go down there and
between the bomber uh bombarra damorera
thing of me couldn't follow him dom and
bombing
there was a couple guys and i just got a
thing in my mind that i couldn't follow
and i'd bomb whatever i'd [__] follow
him so this went on
for a year so i was always kind of
depressed on saturday nights
not depressed but i wasn't like here we
go again i'm going to get down and i get
tortured i'm going to bomb and then i'm
going to bomb a bigger debt
the only thing i'm getting out of this
tonight is 215
15 from my original room set
and the deuce for the [__] main room
set
so
i get down to the main room i come on
stage and guess what
same result there's [__] nine people
in the audience oh look out we got
another drunk scraggle that's coming in
don't start your material until he sits
down you know
but i look in the middle of the room and
it's uh harry basil
charlie hill god rest his soul
alan stephens these are all old school
comics from the store
they all worked with kenneth and dice
that's what the heyday of the store mike
binder
all those [__] would go on
there on saturdays they were old-timers
they weren't on the road anymore they
were just going up to the hang i think
charlie hill still did spots up there
now here's ironic charlie hill
was a [__] great guy he was uh
american indian comic you know
you know my name
i changed my name my name used to be
mountain but i shortened it to hill like
that type those type of jokes and [__] i
love that [__] okay guys i love it i
don't give a [__]
charlie hill was my boy i loved charlie
you know i loved alan stevens and basil
like i knew him from the hallways like
hi
they were [__] royalty i was a
[__]
i'm going up in the main room at one
o'clock nobody wants to talk to me me
and tripoli are going up late nobody
would talk to us
and one night i'm in the hallway you
know i had seen them up there a couple
weeks like every other week they would
go up there and just goof around and
drink on a saturday and they'd leave
like a 12 30 one just guys trying to get
out you know going on to hang out
watching some stand-up
at the time alan
stevens was uh
he's always a great guy alan but alan
was
one of the producers on our list
so they were all coming up on monday i
didn't know what basil was doing
and charlie hill and some other guys i
didn't know what they were doing and one
night i got off the stage
and [__] charlie hill comes up to me
he's like joey you really made me laugh
tonight i just wanted to hug him and cry
like i said on saturday nights
funny was the last thing on my mind so
for him to come up to me and say you
were funny
he goes you give me belly laughs
he goes joey you were giving me belly
laughs up there and there was nine
[__] people
he goes keep doing what you're doing i'm
like thank you mr hill the whole [__]
day sure week was something different
one saturday i get the hell out of there
and i bump into them in l.a man that was
a great set tonight and [__]
basil said to me joey what are you doing
this week and i go nothing he goes i
might have an audition for you he goes
write down your agent's uh information
like all right
i write down my information again when
somebody asks you you know
they got a job for you okay you know
whatever take it again you don't hold it
uh personal you
they were thinking of you
you know and sometimes it goes through
sometimes they actually take it back to
the supervising casting director or
whatever and they go nah nah we're gonna
go with this person but at least they
thought of you
harry came up to me he goes you know uh
blah blah and i wrote my name and i
thought it was very nice he also invited
me to his home
to watch uh he was a big fight buff so
he would always have like a good boxing
matches great guy harry baseball
saturday nights i'm always doing comedy
harry now is
he runs the laugh factory in reno
and in vegas that's how good of a
[__] he is so
harry comes up to me i got to give you
something this week i'll call you give
me your number sure enough i got a call
from my agent
and she goes i just got a call here i
have an audition for you
for the new rodney dangerfield movie
i'm like what
she goes joey you're going in for the
rodney dangerfield movie open up your
[__] ears what's the matter with you
go to uh whatever
get the sides facts to you and go in
there at 1 30 or something
i'm not thinking anything of it
then all of a sudden i get a text and a
tarot basil a page and it's harry base
and he goes hey
just to let you know we called your
agent you're coming in for the audition
today it was harry
who got me the audition
for rodney's movie
okay guys so
i do what i got to do that morning
i learned these [__] sides backwards
and forwards i know them in spanish
japanese english
i [__] know i stayed up all night
you know there's a rodney movie
guys i go in the waiting room i signed
my name i have my headshot with my
little [__] [__] bio with the couple
fake credits and [__]
[Music]
and they go joey diaz i get up i go in
how you doing
and i walk in the room it's [__]
harry basil
and [__] rodney dangerfield
guys this is too [__] surreal for
uncle joey i told you guys
listen in life
if you put the [__] work in from your
[__] heart don't worry about what
mike's doing don't worry about what
joey's doing
don't worry about what lee's doing the
steve simone just worry about what
you're doing the universe will [__]
give you light
listen i
i never belonged in l.a like if you look
at me i never belong if you hear me on
rogue and you know it that wasn't my
world i don't want i'm not fake i don't
need them that's not my [__] world
you know but
rodney was my [__] world
you know so when i walked in that room
when i saw rodney i was like holy [__]
and they're like sit you know tell us
about yourself i told them
i'm a comic i didn't [__] kiss
rodney's ass in the room
i was just i'm a fan i loved easy money
you know but he's like thank you
and also and i read the [__] sides
and in my world i hit him out of the
park i was prepared guys
[__] rodney turns around he goes
jojo
you were great
he goes
i just gave away that roll though
i was like god
damn it
i shake it rodney's hand
i'm walking out the door i hit the
[__] street
and i hear somebody go joey and it was
harry basil
and he goes listen bro
rodney wants you for this [__] movie
he gave away that role
but he wants you to come in
and he'll find something for you are you
guys here's a kid
i don't know if you watch the [__] uh
uh the podcast i did a couple weeks ago
with what's his name
ryan sickler
i was talking about agents
at that time in 2003 2004 guys i was
working my butt off
just working your ass off
i'm doing movies i'm going to [__]
act and i'm not doing big movies i'm
doing
student [__] movies okay
because i want to be good at my craft
i'm doing [__] student movies i'm not
getting paid when you think when do you
shoot those student movies or you think
you shoot those at [__]
two in the in the afternoon you shoot
those at two in the morning because
there's no money
so you have to shoot those late 11
o'clock and [__] you guys have no idea i
was getting no
here's all my friends here's r e runners
easy
all these [__] got caa
josh wolfe they got [__] three yards
this guy's got gersh this i'm with the
[__] coloring book
okay the coloring book agency an agency
that was a kids agency
she really liked me and she wanted to
start working with adults
it was owned by two african-american
sisters badass
dangerous [__]
one was an attorney and one really new
[__] casting like really new casting
so they [__] drilled out they got me
they got me a couple [__] movies
she got me a couple tv shows she got me
mad tv
i always liked them a lot and i'll never
forget like i had the [__] coloring
book guys
i never got invited to montreal
nobody ever thought about me
[__] nobody
you know i was at the store struggling
[__] finding my way
i think i got a a tv show that nobody
saw national lampoon
with rich voss and [__] uh brian
holtzmann down
guys nothing
nothing so how the [__] do you think i
felt when [__] this kid this
sweetheart of a kid harry basil
runs out to sunset
to tell me that
they gave away the role
but rodney's gonna write a [__] role
for me what do you think i felt like
after that
do you have any [__] idea you know
what i felt like like all you
[__] could suck my dick
all you [__] could suck my dick
i booked two movies
yeah i was in the longest yard and this
and this but i booked two movies that
were crucial to my career that were
crucial for me to stay in the business
and those two movies
were analyzed that
and the rodney movie because in my world
there's not too many [__]
better than rodney dangerfield
and in the writing aspect of it there's
not too many [__] in the
writing movie business
that did the damage harold ramos did
in the late 70s early 80s he was a
[__] genius he came from sitv in
canada
a [__] shout out to the [__]
canada producing him john candy all
these [__] with an improv troop
doing like a weekly show sinai live
hooked them all up but they didn't take
harold ramos now for guys like me mike
you at home watching
can you imagine being around with five
guys the last three years putting your
heart out do you know what that's like
the camaraderie mike's got kids i got
kids but every night we still meet at
the cha-cha cafe to do [__] sketches
and we write sketches and then we go
drink coffee till two in the morning to
write sketches can you imagine after two
or three years of doing that
your five buddies got a tv show and you
didn't
what would you feel like
this [__]
went and wrote like
caddyshack
you know listen guys i don't even
ghostbusters i mean
how ramis did this [__] [__] that you
know you so most people if i didn't hire
you would go fold under a [__] tree
harry raymus said you don't want to hire
me on saturday live that show sucks
anyway number one and number two
i'm gonna rock your [__] world what
i'm gonna come out with ghostbusters
caddy shack stripes you know this is
just off the top of my head that i
remember now i remember i did [__] a
thousand milligrams of abx
last night i needed to sleep deep i
slept deep in the rem level with my
[__] uh oh i was deep
deep in the rem sleep last night
and saturday night too i a thousand
milligrams so anyway i don't remember at
all his other [__] accomplishments
but my goal
when i got to l.a wasn't though i i
never thought i'd even have the
opportunity to work with
rodney or [__] harold ramus
but both those guys set me straight
set me straight on who the [__] i was
especially around the danger field
so when ray uh
you know when uh
whatever his name was told me i had the
movie
uh it was like a week later i had to go
to wardrobe and then
the movie's available it's not a [__]
all-star movie but guys there's a lot of
stars in that movie the fat
the fat scientology just chick christie
[__] one of those
brothers this in that movie paul
rodriguez
oh my god it's got an all-star [__]
lineup that movie none of us did
anything with it but it really the
harlan williams
the guy from vacation i mean there's a
lot of hitters and back by midnight i
didn't know this at the time
i showed up to the set
and i'll never forget that i got that
i'm like how you doing i'm joe diaz uh
[__] uh
i'm here to work on the movie they're
like your name ain't on the list and i'm
like and often i see
uh the [__] dude from the laugh
factory walking like oh hey harry i'm
here and he's like come on let him
through and all this [__]
and they'd take me with that they're
like we don't know
what we want to do with you today we got
to go ask rodney so
we walked to rodney's trailer i can't
believe
fat little [__] joey diaz ex-felon
joey diaz
is walking with harry basel
to rodney dangerfield's trailer to find
out what i'm doing that day
we knocked on the [__] door
rodney opens the door
with a [__] uh with a [__] robe
and his balls hanging out and he's
smoking a number
when i saw rodney with a joint his hand
i didn't want to smoke with him i'm not
one of those [__] idiot types
i was so [__] happy that my [__]
idol smoke dope
so i'm like how you doing mr dangerfield
i'm here first off it's rodney okay kid
number two your name is jojo
that's your name in this movie it's jojo
i'm just gonna call you jojo
i don't know what i want to do with you
yet stay close to me so i went and
changed
and they told me to stay close to rodney
all day like you guys know me man
you know i don't
get
i don't get giggly about little [__]
stupid [__]
guys i was like a little [__] girl
next to rodney i didn't talk to him
i didn't bother him i didn't ask him
questions
i just watched the man
at the time he wasn't the rodney that we
all got to see he was an older rodney
his eyes were constantly bloodshot he
had
bags under his eyes and he couldn't
remember his lines
you had to read his lines to him from
across the room
it didn't make for a good movie didn't
one of the academy awards i think four
people saw it
comedy central plays it at two in the
morning
once a year out of sympathy
it didn't matter to me it didn't matter
if the movie sucked
that's what you guys never understood
you know last night the money saints in
newark came on hbo
the sopranos were on all day yesterday i
didn't know why
and then i put the
tv on to get the weather from last night
because we were thinking
or saturday saturday we were thinking of
going up to north bergen
and saturday the many saints premiered
you know and i saw that it was coming on
i had to leave i didn't watch or
anything it was coming on later on
and even i thought about that you know i
thought about how
that movie didn't do well what do you
want me to do i'm going to shoot myself
you guys don't understand why i did that
movie i did that movie for the education
i didn't care about the money i didn't
care if i won an academy award i in my
personal opinion i wish i would have
done a little better
but hey you don't understand what it did
for me
so when whenever back by midnight is on
i always get hate mail like what the
[__] was that rodney it doesn't matter
do you have
do you have the idea of what he did for
me
by putting me in that movie
nobody else would [__] talk to me
nobody wanted to talk to me i was a
criminal i snorted coke rodney
hand-picked me
for his [__] movie
that was more important to me it's like
i look at all this [__] now with
stand-up comedy and i'm unwinding let me
tell you something at the end of the day
i got handpicked by mitzi shaw
you don't think i'm funny whatever go
[__] yourself i got hand picked by misty
shaw and i also got handpicked by rodney
so for all the people who ran all the
festivals
you know what i'm saying all the
festivals and we're gonna have so much
fun
and they didn't pick me i never got my
feelings hurt because it didn't really
matter what you thought
rodney
thought i had it in my world that's all
i i need what am i always saying that
[__] thing
i said you need three people to take
over a [__] country i need three bad
[__] to take over a [__]
country and in my world i did i had
mitzi
i had rodney
and i had harold ramus
i had a relationship with them i got to
talk to them they touched my heart i
touched their heart i don't know if i
did or not
but i took their word over everybody
else's i didn't give a [__]
what any of those [__] agents
casting directors
anything anybody who's got to do with
comedy and comes up to me with a story
unless you're on that stage
i tell you what you go [__] yourself
before you come over here talking about
any [__] comment not just me
so do you understand when i said that on
stage that night that's where it all
came from it came from knowledge
i took over a [__] listen
i'm a sack of [__] and i took over that
comedy [__] they could all suck
my dick
and it wasn't because i went to montreal
it wasn't because i was on the road with
jed appletoe
none of that [__]
it was because the balls i got put into
my hand i thought i got to work with the
holy trinity
by 2004 i had worked with the holy
trinity
and you were in no danger if you thought
you were going to [__] stop me i
didn't give a [__] you know rodney got
me on the track and then howard ramus
polished me up he's like [__] these
[__]
he goes i watch you stand up and i watch
your auditions
if they don't want your montreal they
could suck your dick if they don't want
you for this festival they could suck
your dick
you're the real [__] deal you're here
with me you're talking to de niro you
think i would have brought you in here
if this was a flash in the [__] pan
so when harold raymond told me that [__]
i was like
[__] these [__] comedy clubs i
remember i called the comedy club i'm
not going to tell you the name of the
comedy club
like in 2010 it's a comedy club in the
area here
i called them up and i'm like listen i'm
from jersey i was in the longest show i
like to play your club
and he goes what's your name and i go
joey diaz he goes i never heard of you
[__] you and i'm like you know what i
never heard of you either [__] sucker go
[__] yourself but if you want watch this
watch the longest yard maybe you'll get
to know now me and the guy are tight he
doesn't remember our conversation
10 years ago yeah
no he's a good guy he never remembered
our conversation but even those type of
calls i always told people to suck my
dick hey send me a tape you know what
rodney didn't want to take
what do you want to tape who the [__]
are you
hey send me a tape how are raymond
stephen on the tape that guy wrote
[__] ghostbusters who the [__] are
you some comedy club in [__] new
mexico and i gotta send you a tape you
could suck my [__] dick
so when i come to you people i talk
about rodney
or the you know today's obviously it's a
comedy podcast on a monday not really
it's just trying to tell you
about who lit a [__] fire under my
ass and where i came from
that's where i came from that's the
school where i came from way before
rogan said it or anybody else said it
my confidence level was out of the roof
by 2004 because
the guy i admired in the comedy world
gave me a nod
that's it that i go on the road i didn't
need to
just being i think i worked nine days on
that movie
that movie was a first for a lot of
things for me because
if you at that time i was either i did
taxi and i was in the beginning of the
movie i'm rolling on the bicycle and the
credits are rolling analyze that the
credits are rolling i got shot i always
had i never had the perfect scenario
now
i'm in a movie for [__] nine days
most money i've ever made but the movie
sucks
you never get what you want
but you get what you need
and that's a podcast for today
monday the [__] 21st of march
month is moving [__] we're moving
koval's over get on the [__] bus
we're going down the hill 90 miles an
hour all that [__] came to an end so
we're here
we're queer it's monday it's the 21st
and we're onward onward i love you
[__] with all my heart have a
great [__] monday
thank you for the support and love and
now for a word for my [__]
sponsors jack
what's happening you bad [__] i
want to thank you for watching today you
know what guys i'm lining up all these
guests for you and obviously you like me
talking [__] by myself on a [__]
monday which i like too but wednesday
but anyway the joint is brought to you
by liquid iv
listen you want the best when you're
working out right the best jim the best
trainer
liquid iv is [__] tremendous i didn't
know how good it was like i got covered
one stick of liquid iv and 16 ounces of
water forget about it you'll be tip top
magoo hydrated and ready to [__] run
jump throw karate kicks made with
premium ingredients liquid iv is vegan
non-gmo and gluten-free dairy and soy
plus they're supporting line workers
they take care of everybody they've
donated over 19 million service to ems
food banks veterans active military
there's a great company to do business
with let me tell you something else the
product is sensational they sell it
nationwide at costco knock yourself out
uncle joey's here to save you 25
on a monday morning or for liquidity.com
just by using code joey at checkout
that's 25 of anything you order when you
use promo code joey at liquidity.com
start with the grape you'll be [__]
tweeting me saying joey you're a [__]
genius
experience better hydration
at liquidity.com
the joint is also brought to you by one
of my [__] favorites you know i like
to smell good
and i like everything to be in order and
that's manscape if you smell something
weird right now you're [__]
four two feet away from your nut sack
they're probably [__] reeking through
the [__] jeans you filthy animal
never fear uncle joey and manscape are
sending you to the [__] showers
you're gonna save big by going to
manscape.com
and getting 20 off and free shipping
with code kodia listen a shower is the
best part of the day you can bang one
out
then after you bang one out you little
[__]
use your lawnmower 4.0 it's waterproof
then you lather on a little ultra
premium body wash tremendous with aloe
vera to moisturize all day long then you
do the two in one shampoo conditioner
for your hair your ball sack your leg
hair
then you want no bo right you don't want
to be [__] stinking up a storm like a
[__] onion so you get a little
aluminum free deodorant
and then if you got tattoos or dry skin
they even got a hydrating body
moisturizing spray listen manscape's got
you covered from a to z plus now they're
giving you 20 off and free shipping at
code
diaz at manscape.com
listen
you need to wash your nuts back and be
ready
the sum is coming you don't want the
wolf man looking at your dick
i'm going to give you 20 off free
shipping at manscape.com when you use
promo code diaz d-i-a-z it's time to get
wet and clean your [__] body you
filthy animal manscape shower routine
i'm gonna put it on video soon so go to
manscape.com and the joint is brought to
you by on it when it comes to
supplements honor is number two to
nobody they are number one with the
shroom tech the alpha brain the new mood
the vanilla the mexican chocolate
protein powder [__] tremendous go to
on it and press code joey your church
and get 10 percent off delivered right
to your crib i want to thank liquid iv
i want to thank manscape i want to thank
on it
and i want to thank you guys for having
us back again this week
it's a beautiful [__] day to be alive
go enjoy [__] stay black i'll see
you [__] wednesday tip top
magoo
[Music]
so
you